vaccine hesitancy continues to be a
persistent problem in the united states
only 58.8 percent of people 12 and older
in the us are fully vaccinated for some
that's led to difficult conversations
with vaccine hesitant friends and family
so psychiatrist dr sue varma joins us
now with some ideas for navigating these
difficult conversations uh so good to
see you this morning and i'm so happy
we're having a conversation about this
what would be
your advice for people to understand the
best way to approach having a
conversation with a friend a family or a
loved one
vlad great to see you and great to join
you on this topic it's so important that
we have
a sort of open mind neutral stance and
sort of compassionate and empathic
outlook and that might seem like the
farthest thing from our mind right now
because we're saying we are angry we
want to move forward with our lives this
is not safe and there are three things
that i think of we call them the three
c's of vaccine hesitancy is the person
that you're talking to feeling
complacent they might say to themselves
i don't have a risk of getting this
virus and i don't have a risk of getting
sick from it and it's very interesting
because if we look at the unvaccinated
folks 29 of them actually don't think
that they're at risk for getting covet
as compared to 17 percent of vaccinated
people that means they estimate the risk
to them as being much lower the
unvaccinated group the next thing is
confidence do they feel safe do they
feel as if that they're going to benefit
from them and lastly we want to look at
convenience do they think that they're
going to get sick do they think that
they're going to make miss a day of work
are they going to have side effects and
this is so important because when we
look at who the vaccinated unvaccinated
population is a lot of them happen to
also be uninsured and for a lot of
people who are uninsured we're talking
about people who might be
you know don't have facility don't have
access to health care don't have trust
in the health care system so that's
really important for us to understand
the context in which the person is
refusing a vaccine and here's another
thing vlad low vaccine hesitancy doesn't
necessarily mean acceptance so we want
to push them in that direction with
credible information
dr varma the three c's of vaccine
hesitancy there i think a lot of
americans watching might add a fourth
seed ends in y i think you can think
about what it might be and and on that
subject
the reason some of the people we're
dealing with in our personal lives uh
are so confounding to us is because they
bought into theories or ideas that are
completely false online how do you go
about having a conversation with
somebody where you correct them or lead
them toward the best available science
and information
such a great question tony and congrats
on the new board um you know look this
is a very tough situation because a lot
of times
we are butting heads with people when we
keep throwing facts and science which is
great and there are some people who can
work with you on that and some people
who are in that sort of i don't know
give me the information let me feel safe
go with me to the vaccine get me a good
health care provider that's gonna you
know give me the vaccine those people
might be more amenable but if you have
people who are firmly rooted and have
been for years and that's going to tell
you that look you're probably not going
to get a far with them talk about
personal stories talk about people you
know talk about yourself talk about your
own reasons tell them you love them but
what you want to do
is not alienate them and we're going to
end up alienating people when we keep
pushing facts and signs which are great
for some people who can handle it but
for a lot of people they're going to get
defensive and they're going to push you
away so stick with the personal stories
about people who've gotten harmed people
who've died and tell them how you it
makes you feel how afraid you are for
their life how you are afraid of the
people that are around them who might
get sick from them and dr varma in some
cases though you can tell as you get
closer you're not going to reach the
same conclusion or change somebody's
mind sort of two-fold how do you end
that conversation and is it okay if you
cut ties with people over this as we've
heard some people doing
absolutely um and this is a very
delicate question because it's not a one
size fits all approach there might be a
loved one in your life who needs your
help for a variety of reasons and
they're unvaccinated so i think it's
really important that you figure out
what those boundaries are for example
you may not want to invite them to an
indoor gathering right but you might be
willing to meet with them outdoors or
talk to them on the phone
keep that lifeline open keep that line
of communication open if your mental
health is being impacted because i know
a lot of people are saying i don't feel
like i know this person anymore i
thought we were eye to eye i know a lot
of people who are health care providers
who are deciding not to get the vaccine
despite having access to all the
information and taking care of very sick
patients with covid so keeping the lines
of communication open because what we
know is isolation and alienation breeds
misinformation so we don't want to make
the person feel further isolated and
have them go down dark rabbit holes of
conspiracy theories when they're by
themselves such a good point you don't
want to expel people from your life but
you do want to keep yourself safe and
your closest family dr sue varma thank
you very much for those reassuring words